pleasure to be here today and to be able
to interact with many of you throughout
the day I my talk today is going to be
about thinking about social media and
other similar platforms of social
engagement that are becoming more and
more popular and thinking about what
would be ways for for us to use them as
a sensor of our health and well-being so
I'm going to talk about several projects
in this domain and as I go through them
I'm gonna sort of bring to the fore the
opportunities that lie using this kind
of a new source of data and also the
challenges that come with it
okay so I guess I don't need to spend
much time telling you that social media
platforms like Twitter and Facebook are
ubiquitous more and more people are
adopting these platforms over several
years now and they're using them to not
just seek information about what
interests them but also to share
information about small and big
happenings in their lives so for
instance the birth of a child moving to
a new place or visiting Stanford so over
the years a new field has emerged
we called the computational social
science it has both computer science and
social scientists on board but the
common goals in this space is often to
take this rich stream of data and try to
bring them to bear on understanding
human behavior human moods human
emotions and so forth so um the question
arises what kinds of attributes of human
behavior can this kind of data tell us
it ranges from our emotion it goes to
our social interactions or how we talk
to other people on these platforms and
also we can get a peek into the language
that people are using to interact and
express emotions on this platform
so when we put all these attributes
together what can we do we can do a lot
of things ranging from predicting the
elections to the stock market but what
I'm going to talk about today is how can
we use that reason about our mental
health and well-being so the question
arises why mental health right so mental
health is a kind of concern that we face
that relates to our behavior very very
deeply there are other motivations to
look into the space it's a significant
public health challenge as well as you
can see on this map it affects almost
all countries of the world and what
makes it more challenging is that it's a
kind of a health challenge that is
considered to be socially stigmatized
that is people are not comfortable
talking about this challenge with others
this makes identifying people with these
kinds of challenges really really
difficult so most of the statistics that
you would hear about mental illness like
depression and suicide are actually
severely underreported so we were
thinking can we actually bring some of
these new forms of data which are being
generated in a naturalistic way people
are already on these platforms talking
about what is going on in their lives
and use those data in ways that can give
us a peek into this very important
health challenge the short answer is yes
and throughout the rest of the talk I'm
going to tell you how to go about it so
this is kind of a general structure
we're gonna first look at different
problems that touch on the opportunities
that lie in using social media content
and computational approaches to reason
about well-being so the the reasons
someone might be interested to do that
is because it can help in early
diagnosis we can think about building
risk detection or early warning systems
that can tell us who is likely to have
these challenges going forward we can
also think about new
forms of interventions that could
leverage platforms like social media to
provide therapy or social and emotional
support to those who are struggling with
these challenges and finally none of it
is without challenges so we are gonna
talk a little bit about the different
forms of privacy ethical and policy
related challenges that lie in this
field when we're trying to bring a sort
of non-conventional source of data to
bear on a rather sensitive challenge of
human life so the first project I'm
going to talk about and a couple of them
going forward looks at these different
major life events that happen that blood
offers experience and to think of social
media as a way to see how behavior and
people's emotional and mental health
challenges shift around those events the
first event that I'm going to talk about
is the birth of a child at the birth of
a child is a very very significant event
that affects many of our lives
it is also an event that a lot of us
take to social media to talk about to
announce that someone had a child in
their family so we wanted to sort of use
that this life event to understand and
reason about the kinds of shifts that
new mothers experience and how we can
glean those changes using Twitter data
we started by looking at new mothers who
reported on Twitter that they just had a
child for that purpose we looked at
specific structures of birth
announcements that we bootstrapped from
a set of newspaper articles so typically
when when people are announcing child
birth they mentioned the name of the
child the gender of the child how much
the child weighs what is the size of the
child and so forth so we looked for
those linguistic constructs in Twitter
data to identify who could potentially
be announcing child births and then we
applied a gender classifier on top of
that to identify
who likely were females and as a third
step we brought in some crowd workers to
identify if these are actually the
mothers who were reporting the birth of
their child instead of let's say the
grandmother or the aunt or of female
friend following that we collected the
entire timelines of the set of new
mothers from Twitter data the question
was now using all that all this data how
do we quantify behavior so we came up
with a number of different measures our
measures spanned four categories to
start with we looked at different
measures of activity on the platform so
for instance their volume of activity
how socially interactive they were how
much they engaged in sharing external
information whether they were asking
questions on the platforms and so forth
we had two measures of the egocentric
social network of the mothers given by
the number of followers and followings
on Twitter we had four measures of
effect our more broadly moods that were
expressed through the tweets
so our first two dimensions were
positive effect and negative effect you
can broadly think of them as positive or
negative sentiment and then we had two
other dimensions of effect activation
which measures the intensity of the
emotion and dominance which measures the
controlling power of emotion so for
instance both sad and angry are negative
emotions but angry has more dominance
and more activation compared sadness
then we had our fourth dimension of
behavior change and that related to the
style of the language that manifested in
the posts from the new mothers a style
in psycho linguistics and
sociolinguistics is identified to be a
really really important construct that
actually signals about people's social
environment and how they how they're
experiencing emotionally and secular
so for that purpose we looked for the
mentions of different types of function
words like use of pronouns use of
articles conjunctions prepositions and
so forth so it's the kind of words that
you would actually throw out in any kind
of text mining tasks this is what we
found there are a number of charts here
each of them corresponds to one
behavioral change measure that I just
described there are two lines in each
chart in red you have the mothers in
green you have what we call a background
cohort but you can think of it as a
control group of Twitter users who are
women but who did not report giving
birth to a child there is a vertical
line in blue at the middle of each heart
that is a reporter time of childbirth
so we align all the mothers based on the
reported time of childbirth across a
period following the report of
childbirth and as equally sized period
before the summary here is that the
mothers actually show a pattern of
behavior that is quite different from
what you would see for the background
cohort so for instance they are less
active but that gonna make sense they're
busy they just had one of the most major
life-changing events so they're probably
not on Twitter right but then if you
look at some of the other measures you
would see that they're less positive in
general they're more negative and
they're using more first-person pronouns
there are two questions that arise here
the first one is are these changes that
we are noticing is it more specific or
market for a subset of the new mothers
and secondly what do these changes
actually mean from a psychological from
a health and well-being standpoint to
answer the first question we looked at
individual level changes to identify if
there are certain mothers who change a
lot more compared to others we found
that the answer is yes so these are heat
maps
on two different measures positive
effect and activation so it's an RGB
scale which means that red means however
larger values blue means very small
values and green means anything in
between there are a small subset of
mothers who are expressing less
positivity in the time period following
childbirth and their emotions are also
less intense we you use some statistical
testing to identify effect sizes of
these changes and we came up with three
categories of changes that the mothers
are expressing first one are the mothers
who change a lot so they are the mothers
with large effect size changes then
there are the mothers who only change a
little
that is the mothers with small effect
size changes and then we have the
control group remember so you wanted to
see broadly how the languages are
changing in general over over the
postpartum period compared to the
prenatal period the table that you see
on top says the number of uni grams or
single words present in the tweets that
are changing significantly over the
postpartum period compared to the
prenatal period and even notice that
that fraction is true is over a quarter
for the mothers who change a lot it's
smaller for the mothers who only change
a little and actually it's really small
for the control group control I mean
what of this depends of course on the
control group being very similar so the
treatment group of pregnant women to
make these quasi calmer comparisons
right how did you achieve that so we try
to control for as many variables between
the control group and the mothers as
possible so for instance we looked at
females we we couldn't validate the age
so age could be widely different but I
would imagine that the age range of
Twitter users are fair
tighter compared to the general
population we control for locations
wherever that we could we could infer
that so we try to match the cohort of
mothers as closely as possible to the
control group so that you know these
changes are not due to other kinds of
confounding factors so these people are
also the ones who posted about the same
time frame as the new mothers so so that
there isn't like yeah so like for
instance the control group is not like
someone who posted today and the mothers
from three years ago because they could
be Twitter changes over time so try to
make sure they're the same time period
as much as possible of course the
limitation is that someone actually
could have had a child just did not
report it on Twitter but you can think
of it as a way to study people who do
take on their Twitter to talk about
life-changing events okay coming back to
the slide what are some of these top
changing uni grants right so if you see
the table below it gives you some
examples to get some qualitative feel of
what are the unique games that are
changing a lot so if you would see these
uni grams on the very right side of the
table these are the uni grams which are
usually emotional in nature and in fact
the positive emotion and uni grams are
actually dropping in their usage and the
post partum period compared to the
prenatal period
so let me wanted to sort of think about
ways that we can actually use language
as a way to distinguish between
different classes of mothers and if so
is there a span of language that would
distinguish these mothers from the
others guiding this you have this small
effects of heart attack which is largely
dominated by the statistical difference
you're seeing sort of what what's what's
the mechanism that's going on here like
what is some of the larger that what
does that mean small effect so it just
means that their language is shifting a
lot
I'll I'll get to that in the next couple
of slides so yeah so the elephant in the
room still is why are these changes
happening right that is that your
question Michael yeah supposed to any
other what like well large effects which
is small Isis one they potentially
cluster but you could imagine clustering
on any other kind of change that you
might have evidenced or clustering on
some difference that the theory in in
that field given you look at people who
are previous issues with depression or
something like this yes it seems that's
the city right now I don't know what
okay yeah I hopefully can answer that
going forward so we came up with a
method we call the greedy differencing
analysis in which our idea was to
identify what was the change span of
language that distinguished the mothers
who changed a lot from the others so how
this method work is we started with the
top changing unigram and we I totally
eliminated one unigram at a time and
computer the language distance between
the mothers who change a lot to the
mothers would change only a little and
the control group so what we found after
through this task is that after
elimination of a little over 1% of the
uni grams the mothers who change a lot
became similar in their linguistic
expression to the mothers who only
change a little and in fact with the
elimination of a little over 10%
they became similar in their linguistic
expression to the control group so we
wanted to sort of think about what do
these changes mean and why are these
shifts happening right potential so we
talked to some social workers colleagues
of ours this was when I was at Microsoft
so we reached out to you Davin talk to
you some social workers there and the
tool was to look into this into the
domain of postpartum depression and they
appointed us to look at language
literature where it has been found that
language could be a pretty powerful
indicator of mental health challenges of
people so clearly there are implications
of this kind of an analysis for the
well-being of individuals but what is
missing here is that we don't actually
know if if these individuals were
suffering from postpartum depression and
what some of these changes actually mean
so we went on to our second study in
which we wanted to collect gold standard
information we ran an online survey in
which we gave a participants who would
be new mothers this questionnaire so
it's known as the patient Health
Questionnaire 9 it's a very well
validated instrument that is used in the
psychiatry space to assess mental
illness in individuals in fact if anyone
goes to a psychiatrist for help this one
are there a couple others like that
would be the first thing that they get
and serves as a starting point for them
to get an assessment of their challenge
and to you know get on to treatment for
those new mothers we went on to get
access to their Facebook feeds as well
if they would consent to this gave us 50
weeks of prenatal data are going
backwards from the reported child birth
and ten weeks going forward we had a
sample of 165 mothers for whom we had
assessments of their mental illness
based on the questionnaire we saw on the
previous slide and also their Facebook
data we borrowed the behavior change
measures that we saw for the Twitter
study in the context of Facebook a four
generalizability and B two also kind of
more deeply go into looking at the
social aspects of these changes beyond
the linguistic aspects because one of
the cues that we found in the in the
literature was was the lack of
sufficient social
access to social support for Enda
vigils who had some form of mental
illness and Facebook being the kind of
platform it is to help us towards
improve social capital and so forth we
wanted to see if you would notice
noticeable changes in access to social
support and capital for the cohort of
mothers who had postpartum depression
challenges so we use the behavioural
change measures to Train regression
regression models our baseline
regression model
used the 50 weeks of prenatal data to
assess the risk of postpartum depression
that the individuals had reported our
second model added ten days of postnatal
data to that then in 20 days and 30 days
and then he had a last model which used
the 30 days of postnatal data alone to
predict who would likely have postpartum
depression and I tell you why we chose
those models so two of the other things
with that we also found the postpartum
depression or pretty much any mental
health literature you would see is that
future mental illness is often very well
predicted by past mental illness and
then it need not be the same kind of
mental illness so for instance
literature says that mothers who have
postpartum depression tend to also have
some other kind of mental health
challenge in the past so the reason we
are using the 50 weeks of prenatal data
is to be able to capture some of those
skills if there was historical evidence
of some kind of mental health challenge
in the past that would give us a signal
of a similar kind of challenge
resurfacing going forward so the now the
question is why 30 days and all those
other numbers in between right so this
was the second part second thing we
found in the in the postpartum
literature and that was that
it typically onsets a month or two after
the birth of a child typically when the
baby blues have worn off so most mothers
experience baby blues and that's just a
part of this whole experience but
some mothers would continue to have
these blues going forward which often
manifests in the form of clinical
depression so we wanted to see that are
they accusing this little phase right
after childbirth when the mothers are
going through these blues that could be
potentially predictive of postpartum
depression going forward best performing
model that you would see here is the
model where we have the 50 weeks of
prenatal data and the 1 month of
postnatal data added to that that
explains 40 more than 48 percent of the
variance in the data so that come tells
us that there are these cues in the
activity and in the social interactions
and the emotions people express on
social media platforms that could
potentially tell us who could be at risk
for a mental health challenge there are
many opportunities and how this kind of
a finding might be used and it goes back
to some of the ones that we laid out
earlier in the talk which is it can
enable early diagnosis we can think of
self-reflection or other early warning
systems that could make mother self
aware that you know they might be at
risk of a type of behavior that deviates
from their past behavior and they could
act on that information by reaching out
for social support or talking to someone
they feel comfortable with or even if
necessary reach out to their caregiver
or doctor the opportunities we realized
are not just limited to these personal
experiences of life-altering events our
other work has shown that events that
happen in the environment or the society
that someone is immersed in can also
have okay it can also be associated with
the kinds of mental health related
expressions we can glean from social
media so some of our other work has
shown that people in Mexico
who have been experiencing violence due
to the drug war have shown markers of
effective desensitization essentially
when violence was going up in those
regions over time we saw a decrease in
the expression of negativity in the
Twitter content you know in one of our
more recent works we also found that
experience of violence in cities can
have some association with the kinds of
emotional expressions that we can see on
social media platforms particularly
Twitter so we looked at a city that has
experienced urban violence significantly
over the years that's Atlanta and we
looked at the expression of emotions
particularly negative effect anger and
anxiety in the tweets in Atlanta and try
to see how previous exposure to urban
violence effects or parades these types
of emotional expression okay so now
they'll go forward and I'll tell you a
little bit about the possibilities of
thinking about not just individual level
assessments of of mental has challenges
but what can third-party organizations
do with this kind of new source of data
so we wanted to see if we can assess
population scale characteristics of this
mental health challenge so for that
purpose we utilized a recruiting
strategy in which we leveraged Amazon's
Mechanical Turk if we gave the crowd
workers again a standardized survey this
time a different one CESD which is a
different instrument that has been
validated in international context so
the phq-9 that we saw earlier it's more
kind of like a u.s.a instrument that is
more popular in the United States but
CESD has been widely used in other
cultures too and given the the known
demographics of Mechanical Turk at that
point in time is we thought that is more
proof
it V this was sort of a the breakdown we
had fairly equal number of males and
females in our data and we asked them if
they would share their public Twitter
handle with us then through those
handles we went back and ear to get all
of their Twitter data backwards from the
date of reported onset of depression so
we also asked them if they had
depression and if so if they have an
approximate knowledge of the onset of
that condition we looked at a much wider
set of variables this time to see
markers what correlated with depression
notably we included measure we call the
insomnia index and that comes from
observations in the literature that says
that individuals with mental health
challenges tend to be more active on the
Internet during the night time we had
more sort of deeper measures of the
social graph we looked at clustering
coefficient we looked at reciprocity and
other network level features to see how
they're related to depression and then
we had among the language measures we
had something we call the depression
lexicon which was a set of tokens or
unicron's bigrams and trigrams that were
obtained from forum in which depressed
individuals went to get support so that
would give us some information about
broadly about the kinds of things that
individuals with depression would talk
about yeah it's interesting
so what you did is you took you
calculated the mean the sort of per user
when they when they their post plus per
hour and then you broke that out by hour
of the game disease per hour and then so
later what you're gonna do is even take
like 2:00 a.m. and then look at the
score there as a future yes okay so I'm
I'm quickly gonna go over those
those findings so we had very similar
observations as we had for the
postpartum depression study so the
insomnia index was kind of interesting
this is what you have here these are the
hours of the day and the depressed class
you would notice that the just the wrong
number of posts per hours fraction
normalized is higher later
later in the night and early in the
morning than during the day we also
wanted to see if we could come up with
some kind of an index that would tell us
about the levels of depression in
communities or populations over
geography so here on the right on the
left you have actual data that is
reported by the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention through
technically an annual survey but
honestly the last one I think that
happened was in 2010 that's called the
BRFSS survey so it assesses the levels
the prevalence of different mental
illnesses in the population and on the
right you have the predicted levels in
the different United States of the
United States using the social media a
depression index and what we find is
that there is a reasonable amount of
correlation not just our application of
these statistics but we were able to
also glean a little bit deeper to see
demographic differences or geographical
differences in the manifestation of
depression so for instance differences
in how men and women experience are
these things as gleaned from Twitter and
also seasonal effects in different
cities in for reported levels of
depression as measured from Twitter okay
so I'm gonna go forward and I'm going to
talk a little bit about the third types
of opportunities that exist yeah so
depression because it's a really a hard
question the pressure could have started
very early diagnosis usually takes too
long and usually people who are
diagnosed with depression they have been
suffering for a long time so it's not
clear to me what the onset of
rezonings on your study yeah so instead
of rough harm so we found that we
phrased it as any point in time when
they knew that they were having
depression
to most people it was the formal
diagnosis but from some for other other
work we have found that it could also be
because they had another mental illness
in the past and they kind of knew that
okay I'm probably experiencing
depression now and that might happen
sometime before a formal appointment
with a clinician so it's it's a rough
time we wanted to get a sense of their
own awareness of this condition because
we thought that the data are going
backwards from there could have cues
that would have predicted this event
okay so I'm going to talk a little bit
about so so far we have seen like
individuals who may be at risk of this
challenge going forward and how we can
bring social media to bear on that put
thinking about these predictive models
but there is also a second part to it
which is the individuals who know that
they are suffering from a mental health
challenge and we are coming to social
media because they're trying to seek
help or to connect with other
individuals who are like them so we
wanted to see what is the potential of
thinking of social media as ways of
interventions or as ways of
psychotherapy going forward so there is
actually a rich literature in FCI and
other related fields that says that
reveals have the important the the value
that online communities have in
improving efficacy of individuals and
helping individuals suffering from a
health challenge go through that so we
won from that literature and we started
to look at these forums on Reddit
especially where individuals are coming
to get help and support on mental health
challenges in particular v's harder to
look at this forum called the suicide
watch it's a public forum it's pretty
dark I
encourage you to go there and look for
posts here's just some examples but this
is a pretty serious place on reddit
where individuals come when they are
actually thinking of ending their lives
it there is throughout reddit this
particular cyber is is subreddit is
recognized as a place where you go
looking for support when someone is
thinking about suicide so now you know
that the question is of course what are
the linguistic and other characteristics
of suicidal ideation and you can think
of using this kind of data to build
classifiers for that but there is a
deeper question there which is that by
the time someone is on these platforms
its kind of pretty late already because
they're already thinking about these
kinds of damaging thoughts how can we
priam this process and maybe utilize
social media and computational math
methods to go more upstream and identify
those individuals who are likely to go
to this forum going forward this comes
from the mental health literature where
it has been found that 80% of attempted
or completed suicides come from
individuals who have some form of mental
health challenge in the past but the
reverse of it which is anyone with a
mental health challenge like depression
a very small percentage fortunately
actually go on to die by suicide so we
wanted to see if there could be ways to
discover these shifts over time so this
is one of our upcoming acai papers and
what we did was to look at mental health
forums on reddit and look at the suicide
watch forum over time over a large
period of time and build a computational
approach that could break these shifts
but of course it's very important to
tease out causal correlational and
causal effects in these kinds of
questions because potentially a lot of a
language that you would see in
suicide watch forum and the Panda mental
health forums are similar like
depression is a common word in both
those forums so that's not a significant
distinguishing attribute we borrowed
from the causal inference literature for
the method that we developed here
particularly we use propensity score
matching that are going to talk a little
bit about going forward to identify
these chips this was a how we collected
the data so we had the mental health
subreddit data to start with we absorbed
that data over a period of time we made
sure that we separated our two classes
of people who had posted on suicide
watch already and those who did not
those who did not we went on to observe
them for a period of time and that was
kind of our ground truth for individuals
went through those shifts versus the
others who did not so for propensity
score metrology we looked at every
single token in our in the content that
is shared on the mental-health forums
and we estimated the difference in
probability of their usage in the two
cohorts that is the ones who went on to
post on suicide watch going forward and
the ones who did not so there were some
pretty interesting findings somewhere
skip skip here and if you see some of
these words or uni grams on top you
would notice that for instance the usage
of the word depression although very
common in both cohorts its usage in the
treatment effect of that token was 30%
higher or its usage was 30% higher in
the individuals who went on to post or
under suicide watch versus the ones who
did not similarly the use of the word
useless was 50% higher in in the cohort
who went on to post on suicide watch
versus the others you will see many
other tokens over here like no friends
anxiety loneliness alone which kind of
signal at the social and emotional
experiences of individual
who are known in the literature to go on
to think about suicide going forward
utilizing these findings from the
previous step we built a classifier to
be able to predict who would be likely a
person who would show this shift or
transition to suicide watch going
forward and we had a pretty reasonable
accuracy identifying those two classes
so I think the opportunity and we
believe lies in sort of pre-empting this
process of identifying communities or
sets of people who might be at an
elevated risk of suicidal ideation going
forward versus individuals who have
mental illness but are probably not
gonna be thinking about suicide going
forward and it's powerful because
unfortunately most of the work on
suicidal ideation the data comes from
cases where individuals have already
died by suicide or who have attempted a
suicide which is already it's definitely
late for the former case and probably
pretty late for the other one too so
looking at social media we can think of
these cues that relate to the ideation
process much much earlier than the the
traditional approaches to do so in
interest of time I'm going to talk very
quickly about interventions right so it
must be in the back of your mind all
this while that so what what can we do
with this new kind of data the answer in
many cases that if these interventions
and and honestly we are not the first
ones to think about that there are
people out there who already have been
thinking about interventions using the
internet or using these online platforms
if you would search for suicide which I
don't recommend but if you do this is
what you'll get an 800 number which is
the suicide prevention line if you go on
a Facebook they have rolled out a new
suicide prevention tool as of last year
where someone could report if to see one
of their friends experiencing a kind of
that deviates from the ordinary or TVs
from their otherwise baseline behavior
and Facebook would send an anonymous
message to that individual giving them
access to some resources like hotlines
similarly Instagram has banned certain
types of hashtags that it doesn't feel
aligns with their policies and tumblr
shows what is known what are known as
public service announcements or PSA is
when people search for types of content
that could be dangerous to themselves or
to other people who are reading them so
we there are two problems in this kind
of an approach first of all they're very
blanket or a line nature they could
apply to anyone so they're not they
don't actually know if this person
really has a health Chapman health
challenge or not and secondly the
Facebook one for instance it leverages
the social network of the person and
there could be all kinds of norms
expectations and comfort levels that
could affect whether your friend is
gonna report there someone in their
network to be experiencing a problem or
not but the deeper question is the
effectiveness of these interventions and
one thing that we want to examine is
that are these kinds of blanket
interventions any effective or not what
we found is that for certain kinds of
mental illnesses especially like
especially eating disorders there exists
these communities on social media that
glorifies the adoption and the
maintenance of these challenges so
essentially they promote behaviors that
food
situating is eating disorders as a
legitimate lifestyle choice instead of a
mental health challenge that needs
attention these communities we found are
subverting the kinds of interventions
that Instagram has put in place to curb
the propagation and sharing of these
behaviors so what we found is that
individuals are coming up with lexical
variations variations of the tags which
Instagram has banned to continue to
share Pro eating disorder
type of behavior or type of content so
these charts show you that over time the
extent of variation of the band tags has
been increasing and what we also find is
that for at least several of these band
tanks the activity that is that exists
on Instagram in the period after the
banning was introduced is actually
higher compared to that before because
these individuals are now adopting a
number of different lexical variations
to continue to share these kinds of
dangerous behaviors that they wouldn't
otherwise probably have if they only had
this one hash tag that is now badge
the picture is very complex right so
what do we do I mean we we are seeing
that there are these individuals who are
coming to these platforms some are
probably looking for help so there are
individuals who are sharing through
eating disorder behavior but they
realize that they need to change and
they're looking for help on these
platforms but now there's no way for
them to to share them through regular
tags so they have to go through these
channel of using variations to reach out
to these otherwise fringe communities on
Instagram so we need to think about new
ways of intervening and helping people
and the question arises is that what
would be those ways of intervening and
helping it of course depends on the
individual it also depends on the
platform as we saw that all these
different platforms have different ways
of intervening so we have to think about
ways of how to reach different types of
people on different kinds of platforms
and how can we bring social media to
bear on helping us devise those
interventions but radley the the take
home message is that the cues that we
can glean from social media can be
really powerful in helping us guide
these decisions that would go into
interventions or designing these risk
discovery systems or these early warning
systems relating to someone's meant
health behaviors but one of the
challenges of course is the privacy and
the ethical angle right we have so far
looked only at public data but
potentially these individuals do not
know that they're the kinds of content
that they're sharing on these platforms
could actually be signaling a deeper
underlying psychological concern that
they're experiencing that may or may not
know how do we educate people about it
and how can we think about these
algorithms in in ways that could be not
part of as creepy but to be thought of
as ways that could bring help to people
of course there are questions about who
should have access to these algorithms
right where who owns this data who owns
the findings or the outcomes that these
algorithms are spinning out those are
the questions that whose answer I don't
have but those are the are the questions
that I hope that we will be looking into
going forward because clearly we are
seeing a new emergence of a new kind of
data source that can tell us a lot about
our health and well-being going forward
in ways that have not been possible
before
so not note I'm going to conclude and
happy to take any questions I'm going to
ask one question right now so in terms
of design of interventions right I mean
it's at least from my experience it's
not an organic evolution of sensing
right design interventions has its own
challenges not only efficacy pikas is
one problem but then efficiency they
actually wash down over time even a good
intervention loses power over time and
people just throw it away
or choose the simple ability of getting
access to them or awareness there's a
bunch of problem that share which is
with design an intervention independent
when you and you discover what are your
thoughts about like you know
brought challenger more like public
health issues around interventions
because those who go through that
intervention actually get well but
there's at least on my understanding
there's like more than 95% people who
don't even get access and they didn't go
through there for the intervention have
you been thinking about so you know the
retention problem adoption retention
dropout dog the whole lifecycle of
intervention and and authoring also
because it's like you know engagement
itself it's a challenge yeah it's a very
good question I wish there was a like a
one sentence answer to that but what I
would say is the way I think about the
uniqueness of using this data versus
other forms of data is that this is not
social media platforms were not created
for people to talk about health and
well-being
they were just created because people
want to say stupid things right we all
say stupid things on these platforms and
they are already using those platforms
to serve other purposes in their lives
and if we use the data from these
platforms to build and and deliver
interventions through them then I think
that we have a better shot at making
sure that these interventions are
adopted and retain because people are
gonna come there anyways I mean I can
make an app and push it out to people I
always will have a question of oh maybe
the person uninstalls the app because
it's annoying they don't like it and so
forth
but if it is on on a platform where
they're gonna go to connect with their
friends or to say what they ate for
breakfast anyway that's a good point to
intervene then other standalone systems
I don't have evidence behind what I say
but this is what I hope is the case it
wouldn't be perfect but hopefully it's a
direction worth pursuing really
interesting one thing I'm curious about
is what you think you might find
expanded your feature set beyond
linguistic signals like engrams and
started looking at sub communities like
which sub remnants are they subscribe to
which cell rabbits are they posting
particular I'm wondering if this could
become a sort of moderating variable in
your analysis like maybe like people in
who finds certain sub communities
actually have a reduced for this later
posting in suicide watch and others will
have an amplified
like if that might help get at this
question of does removing the hashtag on
Instagram like amplify it or or to
suppress it like you can imagine you're
right we are looking at that in a
different project where we are trying to
see who would go on to quit smoking
our alcoholism going forward looking at
sub reddits and we find that
participation in non-smoking so session
related sub reddits like anything else
and reddit actually predicts whether
someone will quit or abstain from
smoking or not it's positively
correlated so we believe that they are
actually finding other forms of support
in those places that is that is helping
them towards the skulls so yeah looking
at elsewhere on the platform is is can
be super powerful to kind of get a more
holistic picture of what's going on what
do you think would be similar or
different so if you looked at systems
that are more about tracking like
real-world activities rather than just
what people necessarily post like
Foursquare or like Oh Spencer location
tracking things or you know that kind of
stuff what is the value of those kinds
of I'm just saying so at that point that
you'd have some sort of real-world data
it's a little bit still people doing
impression management at end of the
sidewalk yeah but you know obviously it
imagine some signals like you know
people going out the people are
exercising more yep
you know something absolutely that's
that's a great question and I didn't
have a chance to talk about it but one
of the directions that I started to look
at since getting to tech is how to bring
different forms of sensing to work
together so you know there's work in
sort of wearable sensing and fitness
trackers and whatnot to that tell us
about people's health and wellness and
then there is the stuff on social media
how can we marry the two and also the
third aspect of course which is people's
health records or people's self-reported
information and that those other forms
of data could help us fill in some of
the gaps that exist while using only one
form of data so yeah I mean social media
might be very much about impression
management but when we have those other
forms of data to to sort of interleave
the social media stream you can get a
comprehensive picture about people's
challenges and what's going on and so
forth data full results in treatments
that are better than what we already
have because a lot of the current
treatments we have aren't that great I
mean it's like of the intervention part
is like pretty much unsolved for once we
can necessarily identify that so as
depression or another mental illness so
well that may be identifying lots of
other individuals do you think that
actual treatment can be improved in some
way yeah I really believe so and I think
that this kind of methodology and the
findings could be incorporated in
traditional forms of assessment so for
instance the way psychotherapy today
works is for instance I go up to my
therapist and depending on how severe my
experience is I'm probably gonna meet
them at Mac Mac's once a week or if it's
not that severe probably once a month or
once and two months six months whatnot
so the next time I go to my therapist
there is sort of this gap right the
therapist would ask me questions so how
was your week or how was your last two
weeks did you feel lonely
we're full of energy or not all those
questions but we are prone to forgetting
things and it only gives the therapist
horse information about what may have
happened in that one week but now think
about sort of dairies centric systems or
reflective systems that the that the
patient or I can now share with my
therapist that hey this is what really
happened I posted these things on social
media so some kind of abstracted
information about like trends for
instance or other kinds of aggregated
measurements about my behavior so that
kind of information along with the
questions where the therapist would have
anyway asked kind of empowers them with
knowledge that can inform them better
about what may have been going on in
this person's life over the last one
week then as possible just by asking
questions so I think it has studied
further like digital information about
it is being displayed back to them in a
psychotherapeutic environment like is
that actually a good thing for
psychotherapy yeah I always I always
wonder about that question what if
individuals I mean now it becomes common
knowledge twenty ten years down the line
that yes our data is used to track our
mental illness it just sounds very big
brother' and creepy and negative but you
can think of the positive aspects of it
too because if the data is presented in
a way that doesn't compromise people's
otherwise perceived privacy then this
kind of information could be honestly
don't know but what I can tell you is
that when we did follow-up interviews
for our postpartum studies so we went
back to some of the mothers who gave us
access to their Facebook data and we
shared some of the findings with them we
got tremendous
of course is not generalizable it's it's
a specific community that struggles with
these challenges but we have seen
tremendous support we are also talking
to a support group of moms for trying to
raise awareness about postpartum
depression and they seem to be very
welcome to thinking about digital
technologies that can help them so this
is a anecdotal tiny bit but hopefully
there are promising directions going
forward to use these forms of data
Google Flu Trends so you know if that
worked for a while and then it stopped
working yeah and I wonder if there's a
danger here that this kind of analysis
will stop working you know what do you
what do you think about that is there is
there that thank you so the Lazare work
the laser science paper on why Google
Flu Trends failed outlines two problems
with it
one was the models were not updated
based on the changing nature of the
platform so Google tinker's with its
algorithm all the time so when someone
was searching for flu in 2009 and
getting a set of results that probably
was quite different from what they were
getting in 2013 and they failed to have
failed to change them I'd have the
models to how the platform had evolved
and of course the type of people and
their expectations out of a search
engine also changed over the years so
they couldn't account for those two
things I believe the potential the
potential of this kind of work is is not
in kind of looking at a specific
platform and building these models but
to think of it as one of the many
signals that you can potentially look at
while making these inferences so that
could be a range of different social
media platforms
it could be social media and other kinds
of data that
account for some of these changes over
time signals right you know if you're
saying that we need to add in more and
more signals from other platforms then
it's a little unclear when you can start
acting right
yeah the acting question is a very
important one because honestly speaking
even though we have over 80% accuracy of
our of our methods it's great from an
academic standpoint it's not great from
from an actual intervention standpoint
so I think there is the I mean there are
opportunities to figure out how we can
improve the accuracy of these methods so
that we can actually act on them but
also in the meanwhile I think there's an
opportunity to use them as ways to
empower public health officials or other
people who are making these decisions so
instead of sort of using them as a
standalone system to act on flu or
mental illness use them as ways that the
public health individuals could use to
make those decisions so I'm not saying
it's there's still the need of a human
and the loop may go down right and we
don't have ways of you know changing the
models to make sure that we address the
kinds of problems that address that
Google yeah I mean I I think a lot could
have been addressed if they would update
it they would have updated the models no
one really knows why they didn't do that
these kinds of things
these are the kinds of challenges that
need constant tinkering and monitoring
and figuring out what's going on like if
we build a model and just let it go it's
obviously going to break there's also
the question of human interpretability
in it oftentimes these models that so
complex that if it breaks it's hard for
us to know what was that one feature
that went wrong so there are all these
interesting questions that is not just
about public health or health in general
but also about interpretability of
machine learning how to train people
across domains to act to make these
things useful so see I hope I had a
better answer but that's what I
doesn't let's say the thing that were
one-off model if they were easy enough
to create is that such a bad thing with
where we could just target new models
anytime we needed to my question is more
is there a procedure for generating the
new models like how do you how do you
take into account of that but the models
need to change actually I kind of
follow-up question that because on my
research on stress
you don't look at one eyed event you
look at 79 movements and all of them are
very complex so just getting the
linguistic model for one events quite
complex have 79 so it blew our mind so
we started actually started doing
regular expressions about words and that
we went into semantic models and now
we're doing semantic searching rather
than so semantic accounts for so many
other things that we we're nice guys
here like also like you know just
colloquial expressions oh yeah about SIA
teen depression few people some people
say depression or any of them just say
I'm feeling blue yeah there's so many
ways to say the same thing and if you
look at people posting we used like
Jordan or calm as a baseline what's
really mind-boggling to just keep a
model so we're right now expected with
semantic algorithms to see we can use
just semantic search or you know of
course we find it have you been you know
like looking at semantic you know okay
you guys what was the best predictor of
postpartum depression
it was the usage of first-person
pronouns that's like the first thing we
throw out in any NLP task and that's
because there's a long literature in
psychology that says that high self
attentional focus is a good indicator of
depression so we were almost never
looking into expressions of explicit
depression because many times they
didn't even know that they had
depression so looking at these otherwise
conspicuous cues like usage of articles
which is less use of articles that means
that you're putting less attention to
things around you so you're kind of
disconnected from the environment and
that's a sign of depression so we found
that many of these sort of low-level
kind of linguistic attributes that we
are not
conscious at the time of writing or
sharing I mean who counts the number of
eyes and Me's right that they were super
powerful to get at that so yeah I mean
absolutely it's just there are many
challenges in the language when you
share sometimes these platforms they try
to shut down certain communities that
are like engaging harmful behaviors and
people are kind of motivated to kind of
go around that and they have some
process of doing that didn't can you say
a bit more about comic their motivations
maybe there is something no no about why
they do that or how people even like how
that happens in the community that they
find ways around that and maybe that
would give us ideas of what we could
yeah yeah absolutely that's actually an
ongoing work that we are doing with
Jacob Eisenstein also attack who's the
NLP expert on linguistic variation and
we're trying to see like for the eating
disorder study like okay we see that
this these five variants come up
immediately when this won't this other
tag is banned but then how are they
adopted and why these five variations I
mean there are possibly hundreds of
variations that are possible but these
five are the sticky ones and who are
sort of the early adopters of those
variations and how are people being
influenced by by these new norms and new
practices in this community so there are
many interesting directions to go about
it right now we don't know why this is
happening except that we find a lot of
alignment with adversarial content
detection and and deviant behavior
mining so you would see this kind of a
behavior when you know a spam filtering
algorithm is put in place the spammers
find other ways to share spam now so
it's it's a cat-and-mouse chase
happens in let's say platforms when they
ban abuse related content people find
another way to abuse each other so it's
just I would say innate and human nature
to get around these kinds of third-party
moderation practices and mental health
spaces no exception but there might be
different norms or different kinds of
community dynamics that are driving
these practices compared to like say the
spam some primers or the abusers
you